coming up on Star Talk Our Guest is Dr
Nick tiller he's an exercise
physiologist and we talk about the use
of off label drug prescriptions like
ozempic and other life-changing
Downstream benefits they might hold
in that case it's weight loss but might
it also curb addiction of any kind is
there such a thing as a quick fix all
that and more coming up on StarTalk
[Music]
this is StarTalk Neil deGrasse Tyson
here your personal astrophysicist and
this is special edition where we're
going to be talking about medical quick
fixes
I got with me my two co-hosts Gary Gary
O'Reilly how you doing man I'm good now
all right to be on former Soccer Pro and
sports commentator professionally and we
we they lend him to us for this purpose
gives us street cred anytime we think
about human physiology and sports of
course we got Chuck Nice Chuck how you
doing man hey buddy what's happening
long time co-host and your comedian and
actor all right so Gary you and your
producers like think this stuff up so
clue me in what today is about
um
in a previous episode we explored Quick
Fix Solutions in the health and wellness
industry
yes fixes everything boom there you go
buddy and uh we're not we're not talking
tape and we're out quick fix guys for
everything in life well okay that in
420. um so this show basically was a
must do because right now the quickest
fixes in town are weight loss drugs uh
ozempic and would go be depending on
your preference so that's our point of
entry and from there we'll go off label
on a journey that I think we'll find
pretty interesting and today's guest is
it's fair to say a skeptic he's been on
it before so Neil introduce Our Guest
please oh took Dr Nick tiller who's it's
the second time on start talking a
returning Champion returning Champion a
repeat offender you could say oh there
you go
and I I discovered you I mean not
discovered you but for myself I I
realized you existed upon seeing the
cover of your book The Skeptics guy to
sports science because I know there's so
much
woo-woo and and pseudoscience
circulating in that community and I said
we got to get this guy on the show so
you had him at skeptic yeah the moment
he saw a skeptical yeah
I used that word very very precisely I
knew what I was doing when I when I
titled it that yeah you've got it so you
you have a PhD in respiratory functions
of human physiology your senior research
fellow in exercise physiology at Harbor
UCLA Medical Center very cool leading
Authority on physiology and
pathophysiology love that an extreme
exercise being an ultra marathoner and
Triathlon yourself you would call that
extreme exercise for sure you're a
colonist also for
skeptical Inquirer magazine my single
favorite magazine in the world let the
record show yes everything is indeed I
wait for it to show up and I say how are
people Miss thinking things today and
there it is and then they show it so so
Nick welcome back to start talk it's
great to see you guys again thanks for
having me back so Nick let's just let's
just go straight out all right I every
day I find myself reciting the jingle
for ozempic okay
can you imagine oh so could you imagine
if it was with Govi and they started
with wee-wee
it wouldn't be as good it wouldn't be as
good okay I have a 10 year old daughter
and for the last two years now she walks
up to me and I and it still gets me and
she goes knock knock I say who's there
she goes oh I say oh who and she goes oh
oh oh oh and I'm like really it's good
marketing huh I was like damn that you
were watching too much TV girl I
expected better for her as the daughter
of a comedian just thought I'd put it
out there oh yeah maybe I'm not that
good of a comedian
we've heard a lot about this I knew it
had some uh relevance to to uh diabetes
right for diabetes patients and then
people started losing weight losing
their cravings
and I know people it's an expensive drug
and I know some rich people and
apparently this is just in their regimen
their weekly regimen so it feels like a
wonder drug another quick fix so how do
we go from type 2 diabetes to a weight
loss drug how does that happen well I
guess ozempic was FDA approved so any
drug that become that comes onto the
market has to be approved by the Food
Drug Administration uh so the FDA
approved this in 2017 as a treatment for
type 2 diabetes so type 2 diabetes is
when people produce insulin from the
pancreas but the insulin their insulin
resistance so the insulin that they're
producing is not exerting its effects on
the body and of course insulin's
function is to extract glucose from the
blood to keep blood glucose levels
within a very narrow homeostatic range
and glucose is synonymous in that
example with energy driving your body
needs correct right absolutely glucose
is just a simple carbohydrate so any
type of carbohydrate generally will
cause your blood sugar levels to rise to
some extent
it's one of that that family of osis
right the sucrose fructose
glucose so they're all sugars right yeah
they're all sugars glucose is the
simplest form of sugar there's a single
molecule fructose is another one that's
a single molecule sucrose what we call
table sugar is is a disaccharide so it's
it's glucose and fructose bound together
but it essentially they all get absorbed
through the intestine enter the blood
and they're going to cause a rise in
blood glucose people with diabetes can't
control the blood sugar because of the
reason that I just mentioned that
they're either not producing enough
insulin
diet that's type one okay type two
diabetes they're producing it but it's
not it's not potent enough it's not
exerting its effect your blood sugar
gets too high it can cause systemic
inflammation and all sorts of other
problems and if your blood sugar Falls
too low it's difficult to stay conscious
generally so your body your body will
try body will try to maintain if my
glucose is too level yeah you won't you
don't know because you're unconscious
right well yeah whoever's in the room
with you will know because you'll be
lying horizontal on the floor okay so
your body will do whatever it can to
maintain your blood sugar levels within
this kind of narrow normal dysm static
range so this drug that uh that we call
the zenpick it's called it's called a
glp-1 Agonist and glp1 is glucagon-like
peptide one as a very important role in
the body that when we take in some food
particularly if the food contains fats
and sugars or stimulate the release of
glp-1 which acts on the pancreas which
then stimulate which then releases
insulin is there a term for the drug is
it I mean we've been calling them GOP
ones so the drug itself is called
semaglotide and the brand name is
ozempic so that's what's actually
branded and then FDA approved to treat
type 2 diabetes but shortly after these
drugs were being prescribed to people
with type 2 diabetes Physicians and
scientists found that one of the side I
mean you could call it a side effect or
an additional effect was that people
were losing weight as well which is
generally good because people with type
2 diabetes are often overweight or if
you're obese if you're clinically obese
it predisposes you to type 2 diabetes
and so after a couple of years the drug
was prescribed by physicians off label
which I guess we're going to talk about
in a little while to help people with
weight loss and then in 2021 the FDA
reapproved semacletide under a different
brand name wegovi specifically to help
people to lose weight but it works via
the same kind of mechanism it seems to
me there's an interesting back door here
that you're describing because if FDA
approves a drug for whatever reason and
you find another application for that
drug it doesn't have to be FDA approved
again is that correct
that's correct as long as your doses are
within the range of the originally
intended dose it doesn't have to be
tested that's why everybody loves the
little blue pill
you're right well and that was that's an
interesting one actually because
because well that that was when that was
originally discovered it's um I've got
I've written down some of the drug names
here sildenafil citrate because I can't
remember the drug names but sedentical
citrate was discovered because
researchers were looking at ways to
lower blood pressure right and they
found that this blood pressure lowering
drug had this unintended side effect
that it increased blood flow to the male
genitalia so they rebranded it as Viagra
and the and the weird thing is they now
prescribed Viagra off label to treat
high blood pressure
that's right it's gone full circle it's
gone full circle so what is it about
carrying extra weight specifically
subcutaneous belly fat that leads to
diabetes what is that Association I
never knew the answer for that myself so
yeah what is going on there right so
belly fat is more metabolically active
and it's closer to your viscera to the
internal organs so if you have a large
amount of belly fat it's more likely to
penetrate deep into the into the
viscerin so and Surround your pancreas
and your liver and so forth so because
this fat is more metabolically active it
is it has a much more a much closer
association with disrupted a lot of
blood blood sugar control and signaling
so and this is a problem for men
especially because I don't know if
you've noticed this but men tend to
store more of their body fat around the
midsection women in general tend to
store more of their body fat around
their hips and bums I'm so lucky well
and in effect they are because it's the
it's the fat it's the visceral fat the
central adiposity which predisposes as
you say to type 2 diabetes so that means
men are more prone to type 2 diabetes
than women based on this analysis men
who have greater uh waist to hip ratios
yeah right right so small truck we need
a Sir Mix-A-Lot to do song about men's
belly fat that's right
I like big guts in the camera
all right so Nick
um when patient's been treated the type
2 diabetes with the I call it
semi-glutide but some magnetite it's a
tomato it's a tomato whatever that's
because you're English I know sorry uh
but I don't apologize for that the thing
is you just did
I take it back this is not the apology
you're looking for so so looking at that
and saying to is there enough clinical
evidence to back up this Downstream of
labeling of this stroke as uh as as
another use or is it you know was it
enough of you know what doc or lost
weight fabulous great or is it just got
to go clinically how do you how do you
process this for this drug to come again
in another way
yeah so the only similarities between
the two approval processes is that
cementide semiglutid has already gone
through the phase one and two trials
which are essentially about uh making
sure that that administering the thing
is not going to cause toxic Downstream
effects so the safety profile is kind of
already sort of in place but they'll
they'll study independently for the
independent effects and there are dozens
and dozens of very very good randomized
controlled trials that have looked at
this independently in terms of treating
type 2 diabetes because it helps control
blood glucose and independently using
some aglotide for weight loss because it
is a slightly uh I guess you could could
say it's a slightly different mechanism
so so you have glp1 it has a bunch of
different effects on the body wherever
there's a concentration of glp-1
receptors then glp1 is going to exert
its effects so the first place that we
have receptors is obviously in the
pancreas that we've just discussed so
glp-1 helps to up regulate the the
secretion of insulin and it helps the
beta cells of the pancreas which
actually does the secreting of insulin
to proliferate and it sort of they
increase in number so it can actually
help to treat turkey diabetes in that
way but we know that glp1 also acts on
the stomach and it does so in a way that
suppresses the amount of gastric acid
that's being secreted into the stomach
so obviously when you when you're taking
food you swallow the food down into the
stomach it comes into into contact with
these uh different lipases and different
enzymes to break down the food and
hydrochloric acid and it turns the food
into a into a mushy sludge and it then
empties into the small intestine and
glp1 actually just look at anyone's
throw-up yes right exactly it turns it
into that stuff yeah and but but it but
it does so in a way that it it
suppresses the amount of gastric acid
that's secretes so it takes longer to
break down the food and it slows the
rate of gastric emptying so you
essentially stay Fuller for longer
mechanically you keep more food in your
stomach so it's helped to suppress
appetite in that way but there's there's
one other mechanism that's really
important that we have to mention and
that glp-1 also act on receptors in the
brain so yeah epithalamus is the is the
body's kind of appetite control center
and by stimulating glp-1 receptors in a
hypothalamus then we can actually reduce
appetite increase feelings of satiety
and people want to eat less so is it
true or is this correlation rather than
causation
that
it not only reduces appetite for food it
reduces the other cravings and appetites
including alcohol and you know like
sugar cravings and suppressing urges or
emerges very good thank you is that
where the brain part of this comes in
it's probably not just correlation it
probably is causation the reason that I
say probably is because this all started
because patients who are prescribed some
acletide for one reason or another but
coming back to their doctor saying it's
you know it's not just that I want to
eat less food but my cravings and my
typical addictions like alcohol or even
cigarette smoking have have also been
suppressed yeah so so then we started to
look at this under control conditions
there have been a bunch of studies now
mostly in rodent models so in rats and
mice and a couple of studies in
non-human primates and what we think is
happening the mechanism hasn't been
fully unpacked but what we think is
happening is that uh that glp-1 acts to
down regulate dopamine Transmission in
the brain and dopamine as we know has an
entire episode on dopamine so people
want to look into our archives
absolutely and and when we when we eat
some kind of food particularly if it's
tasty food it contains lots of fat and
sugar the stuff that tastes really good
right we get a dopamine spike in the
brain that makes us it gives us kind of
a nice sensation it reinforces food
related
urges and and uh reward seeking
mechanisms and by down regulating that
pathway then glp-1 can in theory help to
to improve impulse control and decrease
reward seeking behavior and that would
be for whatever stimulates dopamine so
so Nick I have some friends who are
Foodies but like high level high profile
Foodies seeking out the finest chefs in
the finest restaurants those who went on
ozempic
they notice not only did they eat less
but they were deriving less enjoyment
from the food this isn't it worthy
it was a double effect it's like not
only am I not really hungry I don't even
want
and so some of them were worried that it
was subtracting away from them this this
big part of their social life going out
enjoying fine foodie type things
prepared by by high profile chefs you
call this a Michelin star meal you
didn't need a tandemon's epic rating of
this of the meal right it's one of those
repercussions that you don't even think
about but but yeah I guess we have to
frame this in the context that there are
there are two types of feedings there's
what we call homeostatic feeding and
then this hedonic or hedonic feeding and
they kind of they're self-explanatory
but homeostatic feeling is when we eat
because we you know we haven't had
enough calories
you've got to survive right to live not
living to eat if you go out and do a you
know a hard training session or you
haven't eaten for a number of hours then
you're going to have a negative calorie
def you're gonna have a calorie deficit
so your body's going to tell you to go
and eat more and that's almost
homeostatic homeostatic feeding exactly
just in an effort to maintain normal
dynamic equilibrium by the way way you
were that sounds like we're zoo animals
okay it's your feeding time in a way
yeah let's not talk about that thread
and so and so hedonic feeding is
literally is uh is is chasing that
reward seeking Behavior food that makes
us feel good and that explains how we
can go and have a huge Thanksgiving meal
have a big full stomach and still find
ourselves going back to get a second
helping yeah dessert yeah yeah we don't
need the calories but we like the
feeling right so if the feeling doesn't
drive the dopamine you're not even going
to have the thought
right exactly and and that's how this
that's how glp-1 in theory can break
down regulating that process and that's
why you know if we were only if we only
obeyed the homeostatic feeding triggers
right most people would probably be
normal weight because right we would eat
to it looked like everybody in the 1970s
and I know Carrie I know you want to get
in here but it's just showing this right
here just right here I want to stay
right here for one second
wouldn't it make sense then that
neurochemically if we were to just
deprive ourselves
these kind of
um pleasure triggers that our brain
would naturally kind of go into a state
where it doesn't care like we wouldn't
be seeking the rewards so you cut out
sugar for like two weeks right and just
stay off of it like your body will say
all right effort I don't want sugar
anymore you know
well I think it's intuitive but if you
if you ask anybody who's ever followed a
fad diet they can probably cut out all
kinds of junk food and confectionery and
alcohol for six weeks two months you
know they can go for a long time without
that and eventually they fall off the
wagon right this is this kind of
characterizes most people's experiences
with dieting which is why dieting never
works because as soon as you conceive
the idea of a wagon you're gonna fall
off it right so Charlie's answer is no
probably no that there might be some
kind of neurochemical mechanism that I'm
not very you know that I don't fully
understand but um experience tells me
that that's not the case
hey Neil happy sweet 16. what this is
your 16th book coming out the one that
we started working on together two years
ago
this yeah
yeah well thank you yes it's my 16th
book practically forgot about because
I've been very busy and I guess it's
coming out in a month well it's my first
book so oh sorry we gotta do something
sir so I should be more excited that
okay absolutely
but I think this is your best friend
so Nick we've got a neurochemical
process here and it works on addiction
and therefore dopamine our trials
underway for this particular drug to
work on dementia and if so what's the
process in play so most of these
additional effects that we're reading
about so you know but supposedly this
drug can reduce the risk of dementia and
Alzheimer's and polycystic ovary
syndrome and all of these other things
most of that stuff is this is where I
turn into a grumpy old man most of that
stuff's reported by the mainstream media
and you know as they tend to do they
misrepresent the mainstream science so
probably there isn't there is an
indirect relationship between use of
some acletide and the overall risk for
developing Dementia in this case but
it's mediated
by weight loss so we know for example
that people who have type 2 diabetes
have a greater risk for developing
dementia and other kinds of cognitive
decline because of this systemic
inflammation that occurs because of
uncontrolled blood sugar levels right so
if we help type 2 diabetics to better
control their blood sugar
then they in turn they they in turn
reduce their risk of developing uh
dementia and other types of cognitive
dysfunction so there is a very indirect
link there but it doesn't seem to be a
direct mechanism there's some evidence
that maybe grp1 receptor agonists might
help to improve cognition in in some
respects but it's very early stage
research and it's going to be a couple
of years before you before we know
anymore so a lot of the time if you can
decrease somebody's body weight help
them to better control their blood sugar
then their risk for all sorts of things
portfolio that comes in right exactly
it seems to me like we're looking in the
wrong wrong area because from what from
everything I hear about medically
inflammation is the worst thing that can
happen to the body right it's the body's
way of saying look I gotta get rid of
some bad stuff but the reaction to that
is what is harmful why are we not
looking for a way to just stop
inflammation
foreign
exerts its kind of its pathophysiology
is is due to inflammation yeah so
cardiovascular disease for example uh
COPD chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease cigarette smoking is so bad for
you because it exerts systemic
inflammation this is essentially all
about yeah managing inflammation and
we've mentioned even high blood pressure
inflammation is the big problem it seems
to be inflammation even Ultra endurance
exercise which is an area that I've
become interested in it's probably not
super good for you in in some respects
because it it induces this systemic
inflammatory state so yeah trying to
reduce inflammation trying to induce
stress uh physiological and
psychological stress seems to be a
pretty important thing to do so I have a
double s question here this the sort of
a zympic drug that group of drugs gets
released in what 2017
a were they designed specifically to
have these Downstream effects or are we
just slow to realize these benefits
well there was something called covet in
between there yeah
you know just let's get real here but
Nick yes
well I should to try and answer your
question I think I don't think we've
been slow on the uptake to try and
understand we've known about glp-1 so
this is naturally produced glp-1 that's
produced from the intestine in response
it's a hormone isn't it it's a hot it's
a peptide hormone that's produced
naturally in the intestine but and we've
known about the functions of glp-1 for a
long long time but the human derived
glp-1 has a very very short half-life
it's metabolized has a half-life of
about 10 minutes so it's secreted from
the intestine and then it's very very
quickly metabolized only about 15-20
percent of what's produced actually
makes it into the blood which is I have
to insert here because you borrowed the
term Half-Life from physics so in case
people don't precisely know what
Half-Life means the half-life is always
given with an interval of time as Nick
just did so the half-life is 10 minutes
after 10 minutes half of that chemical
remains another 10 minutes half of that
half remains another 10 minutes half of
that half so it's 2 to that power of
having so if you do this three times
it's two times two times two is eight
you have one eighth of what's there so
rapidly within an hour this is I presume
there's insignificant amounts in your in
your system unless it continues to be
produced right and and so and I'm glad
you did the math because there's no
chance I would have been able to do that
but uh but but but and actually that's a
very interesting segue because how glp-1
agonists were first discovered was
actually discovered in the 1990s by a
government-funded research called John
Eng
and he was researching the various
constituents of lizard Venom and so
Chuck what how's your lizard knowledge
and let me tell you I love lizards yeah
oh no I'm sorry that's lizzo
there's become something different all
together all together
well are you are you familiar with the
Hilo monster yes very much we call it
another monster but yeah yeah yeah okay
well so so the the uh the killer monster
has is as far as I'm aware is North
America's only venomous yes lizard yes
and and so and it was the prehistoric
creature of choice in 1950s movies
filmed close up making you think it's
big and bigger than the people running
away from it because it's got that
sticking out and it flops his legs and
it's pretty scary if you've never seen
one before and that was our you know
before Jurassic Park and CGI dinosaurs
that was the best we could do beautiful
well his Venom is also quite scary as
well and this this character John Eng
was researching the various constituents
that made up the the lizard Venom and he
found that there was uh there was a a
protein in in the Venom that had a very
very similar molecular structure to what
we knew then to be glp-1 producing the
human intestine but whereas glp-1 human
glp1 had this very very short half-life
of 10 minutes or so this lizard Venom
this lizard Venom protein had a half
over like five hours so he immediately
thought well if we could find a way to
isolate this and synthesize it maybe we
could administer this administer this to
humans and help with blood glucose
control fast forward a decade over a
decade and the FDA finally approve a
drug called examine a tide which is
based on this lizard Venom protein and
that was that that was our first short
acting glp-1 Agonist and since then
we've developed uh uh geopy one agonists
that have longer and longer half-lives
five hours ten hours and then some
magnetite has a has a half-life of
between five and seven days so it's a
long-acting deal which means it can
exert its effect around the clock
so the the dose is a once a week dose if
I remember correct right it's a weekly
dose yeah twice a day
that's consistent with that information
yeah yeah an xenotype was twice a day so
people would have to jab themselves
twice a day because of the half-life
whatever five towers and not only is
there difficult you know it's difficult
to get people to adhere to that kind of
structure uh they also had to time the
application around meals much like they
had to do with insulin which is a drag
for everybody whereas magnified it's not
a drag if you would Otherwise Die all
right it's preferable to death correct I
thought so what from everything we've
been discussing it does sound like a
miracle drug
so so where where does your skepticism
land in the presence of this drug
relative to all the other drugs that
have claimed to be miracle cures
well I I've I've gone back and forth on
this and I've struggled with this quite
a lot actually because as you as you
kind of allude to for the last more than
a decade of my life I've been very much
an advocate as an exercise scientist and
a skeptic of this idea that any health
and wellness outcome that is worth
achieving has to be what you have to
work for it you have to you have to put
in some time and some effort and some
commitment so as the manager does
triathlons yes right exactly it takes
time you can't we can't get these things
I want to be in the shape that you're in
but I just I don't want to leave the
couch I was going to say Nick we're only
seeing you from uh like uh chest up
shoulders up and and we're like yeah
two and a half percent body fat exactly
sure it's a padded sure
and my storage of some agletide that's
what you don't realize we actually were
ribbing you about looking good but we
didn't let you finish telling us your
convictions on ozempic yeah Mr skeptic
well as an exercise scientist as a
skeptic and for for the longest time
I've always I've always been of the
opinion that to achieve any meaningful
health and wellness change requires time
and effort right and particularly this
obesity and and being overweight is
probably about as complex as a public
health problem can be everybody wants
Simple Solutions to complex problems and
you can't just think run triathlons like
I do and that'll lose your body fat
that's that's not gonna work you comment
you can in some cases if your exercise
volume is so high that you're expending
so much energy then sometimes you know
that that will be enough to do it but
rarely is that the case and so but here
we have a drug that is seemingly safe no
drugs are completely safe there are side
effects which you know maybe maybe we'll
Circle back to but uh it seems to be
apparently safe what one caveat to that
is we don't have studies on people that
have been taking this drug for five or
ten years so we don't know what the very
long long term effects might be
um it's definitely effective you know
the average weight loss in a somaglotide
trial is about 15 of body weight so
that's 30 pounds in a 200 pound
individual I can use that I could do
that definitely clinically meaningful it
will dramatically reduce somebody's risk
of comorbidities
and you know I I hate to say it but
we've been banging this drum about
people improving their Lifestyles and
eating better in this kind of thing for
decades and the only thing that we've
seen change is that obesity rates have
gone up oh yeah and obesity rates have
been training upwards since the 70s
they're now going up exponentially yes
so I so Nick it's a it's an
extraordinary phenomenon and it could be
just that the food industry has figured
out how to make tasty salty fatty uh uh
calorie dense foods that don't cost much
money and push them all day every day on
every media Outlet you can find so here
we go Nick let's flip this if you've got
somebody who is not clinically obese and
is pretty good body weight for their
size and all the rest of it and you give
them uh drug
the weight loss becomes a problem
doesn't then it push other need for
calories and the kind of the addiction
thing doesn't work as well does that
happen no if they weren't overeating to
begin with they were they weren't going
through this dopamine cycle right right
am I right Nick well everyone everyone
has reward related Behavior particularly
when it comes to food most people do so
if you don't yeah or scotch or alcohol
or psychoactive drugs or gambling or
social media everyone has everyone is
constantly pushing that dopamine button
in one way or another and it just so
happens that people who are very
overweight seem to do it more often than
not with food but everyone you know if
you didn't have any dopamine response
you'd have to be a robot essentially but
um but anybody could could potentially
take these drugs and lose more weight
and this is what you know Neil said at
the beginning that he knows he knows you
know celebrities and things who have
been taking a zenpick and I don't know
if you saw the Academy Awards this year
I didn't watch the whole thing but uh
Kimmel was the was the presenter and in
in his opening monologue he joked about
it he said you know I look around and I
see all these slim beautiful people and
I can't help but wonder is ozempic for
me and you know it got a good laugh it
actually cut cut a little bit close to
the Bone because a lot of people who can
afford to pay one thousand two thousand
dollars a month are using the drug when
they don't actually necessarily need it
I have a friend who's on it and uh he
swears by it and I said to him but when
you stop taking it you're going to be
fat again and he was like and so I just
won't stop taking right this is the
other thing and there's I mean they've
done some really really good studies
there was the step four study which was
published 2021 in the Journal of in Jama
Journal of the American Medical
Association and it was a really nicely
execute study they've got a group of
like 800 obese individuals and they put
them all on some agletide they titrated
up the dose for the first 20 weeks so
they started very very low dose every
week they increased the dosage until it
was about 2.4 milligrams per week which
is the recommended dose and in the first
20 weeks everybody lost weight and I
think the average weight loss was about
10 percent of body mass which is pretty
good for 20 weeks work they then split
the group in half half the group
continued on some agletide for the rest
of the trial for it for an extra year
the other group got Placebo injections
right and you you can probably guess
what happened the group that continued
on some acletide continued to lose
weight and I think the average weight
loss by the end of the trials between 15
and 20 body mass the Groupon Placebo
regained pretty much all of the weight
that they originally lost but here's the
kicker everyone in that study was
receiving help with their diet they were
receiving lifestyle coaching and they
were receiving monthly sessions with a
with a psychotherapist to help them with
the you know with the psychology of
appetite suppression
is is it's probably it's not working
something in that trial wasn't working
exactly as Chuck says if somebody starts
taking this drug we better hope that
there are no long-term side effects
because people are going to have to take
it for the rest of their lives if they
want to retain their weight
Where Do We Stand ethically when type 2
diabetes suffers now being forced to
wait for this drug that could be so
beneficial for them because it's become
the drug of choice for lots and lots of
other people don't have for some people
not to take them out of morbid obesity
States but others just to fit into the
clothing that they didn't fit into you
know a year ago so is there enough of
this to go around and to cover the the
people who really need it to save their
life
the sure answer is no so the short
answer is that there's a puppy Supply at
the moment cannot meet the demand and
this is largely because you know it's
been endorsed by a number of of
celebrities and you know and other types
of famous people that's trending on Tick
Tock a lot of Fitness influencers are
using it to you know help facilitate
these dramatic body Transformations and
whereas Physicians are only supposed to
be prescribing these things to to
patients essentially people who are
clinically obese so they add body mass
index more than 30 or people with a BMI
of 27 or more who have an additional
risk factor right or somebody who's
pre-diabetic or diabetic these are all
diagnosable conditions based on clinical
criteria
but you you can't stop a physician from
prescribing it to somebody else who
might ask for it you can't stop people
from getting it online buying it
overseas buying it from friends there is
a way to get hold of this stuff and as a
result as I said Supply cannot meet
demand and this this kind of real
implications for a diabetic who has
become dependent on ozempic now there
are there are other options for type 2
diabetes type 2 diabetics and you know
metformin for example for the longest
time was the the was the go-to treatment
and you can of course inject with
insulin but uh but glp-1 agonists in
terms of controlling blood sugar are
just as good if not better than insulin
and so if somebody's been used to taking
ozempic every single week once a week
and then you ask them to switch to
insulin because there isn't enough
exemptic to go around there's a lot of
trial I don't know if you know somebody
who's got type 2 diabetes or if you've
you know but there's a lot of trial and
error that goes with the administration
of of insulin yeah you've got to figure
out how much to use when to inject it to
track your blood glucose constantly ads
where they have that sort of readable
patch on their shoulder and I'm thinking
wow you're going to monitor it every
time before you eat after you eat in
between meals and what happens after you
have the banana before you eat and so
yeah this is clearly yeah how how soon
before this Market space becomes crowded
with GOP one drugs that will be for
addiction foreign
we use monitor lizards instead good
question we definitely more of something
I mean a lot of these synthetic forms
are now they are going to flood the
market you know some magnetite is is
obviously a highly sought after there
are a bunch of other glp-1 I guess uh
that are in development there's a
there's one actually to zapatide which
is in it's just finished phase three
clinical trials it will be approved by
the FDA probably before the end of the
year and this is a dual action glp-1 Gip
Agonist so it's I won't bother going
into the mechanisms of Gip just for
barity but it uh they're basically
synergistic together and it's even more
effective than some agletide so some
magnetite in the 18-month clinical
trials average weight loss 15 to
zepatite average weight loss 20 or
possibly even more so so this is just
the beginning of glp-1 receptagonists
yeah um I think we're a long way off
prescribing it for anything like
addiction or uh any of these these other
indications no it affects the brain in
hypothalamus or the okay
[Music]
then that has nothing to do really with
whether food or drugs or or
you know alcohol or alcohol right it's
just
the reward system yeah that seems to be
fundamental to so much of what can
derail someone's life Wow sure yeah and
you're absolutely right the implications
of that could be huge but at the moment
as I said this is only being studied
experimentally in in mice and rats and
so we don't know the safety profile of
administering in those kinds of doses we
don't know exactly what dose would be
needed to treat addiction
um I have a lab rat question so they you
know an old mouse is three years old
right so if they go through multiple
Generations or rather
um what am I trying to say you there are
animals that don't live as long as we do
so aren't you allowed to scale the
long-term effects into their short
lifetime to get a sense of it what the
long-term effects might be in us at
least get a first hint at it
you can definitely get a hint at it but
but one thing that that uh scientists
and Physicians uh warn against is giving
somebody a small dose over 10-year
period it doesn't necessarily induce the
same results as giving somebody a high
dose over a very short period it doesn't
always scale very very well okay so we
we can't we can't wait to get these data
in real time because then we'd have to
wait five and ten ten years and and
people are gonna you know become very
unwell in that time everybody notice he
said these data because data are plural
it's a plural noun and if a singular
data is a datum just so you know
right so hey Mick thinking about this
there's going to have to be off-label
legislation right and the control
thereof of prescription of off-label
drugs but who wins the clinical
innovation
or the legislation because if you if you
just Crush Innovation within a clinical
environment what's an incentive to go
forward if you're still waiting that a
period of time
yeah this is a very uh hotly contested
and highly divisive issue because on the
one hand you've got you've got
scientists and Physicians who very much
feel that
that the FDA for example so the FDA uh
the regulatory body for all of the new
drugs that that come onto the market and
the FDA are The Gatekeepers for which
drugs can be promoted commercially by
pharmaceutical companies and some people
think that they are overly bureaucratic
and that in doing so they prevent drugs
or delay drugs getting on the market
that could be helping people right so
that's that's kind of and and these
people will always put forward these you
know hundreds of examples where patients
are waiting for drugs to get approval
and they need these drugs and then the
drugs are finally approved but it comes
too late for these questions
oh yeah that's right at the storyline
and of course uh and there was emergency
some there's some regulatory emergency
bypass that was enabled for coveted
vaccines is that correct right right
yeah yeah so so they were so the actual
approval process was expedited we should
you know hasten to add that these mRNA
vaccines for example have been in
development for a decade but the actual
approval process was expedited for that
very reason because you know hundreds of
thousands of millions of people around
the world were dying already so you
can't wait two or three years that you
would do for the normal process and it
obviously turned out to be the right
choice but at the other end of the
extreme you have people arguing the
opposite that the FDA are they need to
be more bureaucratic they they need to
be more conservative because history is
littered with with instances where the
FDA were premature to approve a drug
that then turned out to have really
nasty side effects I heard left with
that than the other but I I believe you
that they're out there that they wanted
to be even more conservative
yes Ben Fan's a great example so so it
was you know the 1930s 40s 50s a bit the
main drug that we use to treat obesity
the Royal way of course was amphetamine
because amphetamine is a very powerful
stimulant as you know it increases
metabolic rate increases sympathetic dry
helps people burn more calories which is
great it was moderately successful at
helping people lose weight but it was
obviously highly addictive because
amphetamine isn't it is addictive and it
caused all sorts of heart problems and
heart complications then Phentermine was
approved in the late 1960s I think and
Phentermine is a a less powerful
stimulant but it's still kind of exerts
stimulant-like effects and again it was
moderately successful at helping people
to lose weight by working as an appetite
suppressant uh fluoramine was was
approved um shortly after that and then
some bright spark thought thought to
themselves well if we combine these
drugs together we get an even more
potent effect the the thing was um
featured they they eventually did
approve it as Redux which was a which
was featured on the cover of Time
Magazine
there were 18 million prescriptions for
the drug the following year
a hundred Americans died because of
heart problems and 20 of the people who
received a prescription for fenfen or
Redux had to have heart surgery to
correct damaged heart valves so that's
an example of not only will a drug that
was being prescribed off label when it
shouldn't have been but the FDA being
under so much pressure to try and Tackle
this growing you know obesity epidemic
or this increases in population body
weight that they sort of jumped the gun
on the safety profile so understandably
now how often you hear about Americans
having to go to Mexico or to France to
get a drug that's not yet approved by
the FDA right we hear that a lot but on
the yeah on the other side of that uh
may even be worse in the in the in the
full spectrum of Public Health what's
the percentage Nick of off-label drugs
in terms of doctor's prescription
so so just for the listeners who aren't
sure off-label means it's a drug that
has been FDA approved but then a
physician has decided to to write a
prescription uh for something else for
some other indication or in a different
dose or in a population for which you
hasn't already been approved okay and
the it's probably about between 20 and
30 of all prescriptions are for
off-labeled drugs so it's very common it
is not illegal it's uh widely practiced
in the states and around the world
um but I think it probably needs some
better regulation because the FDA of
course they regulate the availability of
new drugs they don't regulate medical
practice so the FDA are very much hands
off when it comes to off leap so either
mechan can be prescribed for covid even
though it's an anti-parasitic right and
exactly so the general criteria for the
or the recommendations for a physician
to prescribe off-label they the drug has
to be supported by scientific evidence
and or sound scientific evidence The
Physician has to lean heavily on their
medical experience and of course the
third thing goes without saying that the
physician has to have the the patient's
best interests at heart the problem with
that is
right exactly first do not harm a
premium but the problem with that is
that
what I consider to be sound scientific
evidence might be very very different to
what somebody else considers to be sound
scientific scientific evidence and if a
physician leans heavily on their medical
experience well what if they don't have
much experience what if they their
experience Pals into comparison you know
relative to their uh you know somebody
internet is for so they can put up a
YouTube video we've seen right exactly
you can just go and watch YouTube we
know for example on the Ivermectin case
you know I read a study that was
published earlier this year that found
that conservative Physicians were more
likely to prescribe Ivermectin and hydro
hydroxychloroquine for treating covid-19
and the the main driver for that was
cable news cable news right you know I
will say this though I took ibramectin
when I had covid and my uh my intestinal
worms were cured drugs straight away I
still kept the worms they just didn't
have covet and you still haven't seen
benefits with the other horses
right yeah actually I can't stop eating
anything
guys you gotta end it we gotta we gotta
Land This Plane Nick this has been a
delight to have you on yet a second time
I know it's not gonna be our last time
because you were a trove of information
and you can hear how curious we are you
know how curious our our fan base would
be as well so thanks for uh this second
appearance on Star talk thank you it's
been great to see you guys again so uh
thanks for having me all right uh Chuck
and and Gary's a pleasure all right
pleasure nail all right the other gas
station special edition this one on
quick fixes real or not
until next time keep looking up
[Music]